un bon coup de pour ne pas mettre
pied à terre
samedi dernier le vélo-club de maurepas
elancourt organisait le quatrième
championnat international de vtt des
uniformes pompiers militaires policiers
90 participants venus de toute la france
pour affronter la colline d'elancourt
vient de haut niveau là il ya du très
très bon niveau on a des gens qui
pourraient qui courent les championnats
de france
en ffc qui font des places et puis on a
on a le randonneurs du dimanche qui
vient ici pour se faire plaisir un
plaisir intense de 9 km pour trois tours
chacun des singles de roullens de la
technique
un circuit éprouvant approuvé par les
puristes c'est un parcours très très
très physique
moi je connaissais un petit peu ce
circuit parce que il fait partie de
leurs revancharde
donc non c'est une artificiel mais
que les tribus une première épreuve
nécessaire pour les coureurs qui
participeront l'an prochain à la manche
régionale et aux championnats du monde
des sapeurs pompiers